Erasmus it's without doubts the best
known European Union program among young
people launched in 1987 its popularity
is once again on the rise and it's only
set to continue with erasmus+ the
european parliament has given the green
light to increase its budget in spite of
the crisis forty-seven percent more will
be injected into the program between
2014 and 2020 that salon was 15 billion
euros rasmus plus will facilitate easier
access to loans and is now also being
extended to sports people the program
will come into effect on the first of
January 2014 transport energy and
telecoms three sectors whose potential
the EU is yet to fully harness the
European Parliament is calling for
funding for a series of large scale
works the goal to interconnect member
states create jobs and drive up growth
no son de envio de la fois pour tous
pour l'énergie a poetic allegations Todd
familia de ocio Seto elevated modo de
passe copia del barroco say a pro
completely culture is being discussed at
European level and emmy peas believe it
has a future they wish to allocate
almost 1.5 billion euros to the sector
for the years 2014 to 2020 through the
art cinema and audiovisual sectors to
name but a few the program seeks to
safeguard Europe's diversity and at the
same time boost employment today some
seven million people work in the EU in
this sector between 4.5 and seven
percent of Europe's gross domestic
product Oh Judy Amidala Roberto metro
que por troppo molto jus toluna caduta
dal do me rossetti a doji della
participate Sione desi tadini a la parte
sua zona a la cultura SIA in modo pass
avoca miss potato SI modo activo
creativo questo valle de la crisi
magickal cosas que no funcionan cobra
nella exceso de tadini a la cultura the
creative Europe program looks too
adidas situation and on a wider scale it
also includes the European Union's
neighboring countries